I hope you would sucky. Yeah. And you gave it a seven.
[Inaudible] to you. That's the one with, uh, things on as he, yeah. That's the,
yeah.
The, the module one. That's the body pillow we have outside. Yeah. Yeah.
I've watched that. You've you've, you've actually watched [inaudible].
[Inaudible] and I, I, at the end, I was like, I'm going to understand Ms. Young.
And at the end, I was like,
I don't understand what I'm like with this golden wind and going on and stuff
like that. And I'm like, I dunno. So again,
it just doesn't seem like a show you would watch.
I watched all of persona for the animation.
I noticed that I noticed that as well, never played persona for persona.
Do that. I did not, I I'll be a hundred pounds with you at the time.
I legitimately didn't know it was a game.
That's like, that's like, wait, did you watch Dungan romper as well? Yeah,
he did. He played Duncan. Give it a four. I happily, but that's fine.
That's fine.
Um, for the shows that I haven't rated, you can ask me and ask me what I'd.
Give it. Like, what would you give a no game, no wife, or that.
If I was, if I was.
Yeah, a hard 10 now, like a seven on a seven.
Okay. It's about that. What'd you give Excel world.
Uh, you know, like a, like a four,
what would you give another look at one
another was. Be got to HK as well, you know? Okay. Actually I did. I love,
we got a hit, like a Gracie.
I can tell you exactly why I watched another as well,
because I was talking to a girl at the time and she was like,
of course my favorite show is another it's the best show. And I was like,
all right, fine. I'll watch this show.
Cause I'm trying to like SIM I'm trying to.
So I'll try another was kind of like the,
kind of like the true crimes documentary.
You know what I mean?
Everyone knows white girls love true crime and before they get into true crime,
you know, they're a little younger than like another erased. Yes. You know,
all these shows that I love.
This is like, yes, I too,
like final destination and watching trashy horror movies.
I can do that all day long.
That's literally what Sydney gets me to do whenever I like I'll give you,
I'll give you props though that you a watched claim all and gave it a night.
Honestly. I love claiming. It's awesome, man. I,
that is one of the enemies that got done most.
Yeah. That's why I'm surprised you gave it a nine because Claymore, Monga,
Monga nine or 10 clay, clay Maga, masterpiece, anime.
Feel things that I hadn't felt before. I was like,
like a level of uncomfortableness that I haven't experienced before. Like,
I don't know why there's something so unnerving and uncomfortable about
watching.
Yeah. I felt that when I worked at Bazaar.
I would like it like you up a little bit. And then I can tell, like, I honestly,
I wish I I'm, I'm going to try my best to try and read the Maga.
But I said I was going to read something. Yeah.
Recently where bought all the Monga. Just cause I want to read it again. Cause.
What was the other show? I said I was going to read the mangrove.
Oh wait, I have no fight. Oh, you finished April 21, right?
Yeah. Yeah. I did. I want to do that. Well, uh, I actually, I downloaded, uh,
Lex first. No, no, no, no. I was going to read that,
but I actually downloaded the first 30 chapters of one piece thing like that.
Oh, he's getting [inaudible] but I haven't, I haven't stopped.
I haven't had pocket marketing.
[inaudible].
I'll tell you when I start, like I'll get,
but I haven't marketing your calendar.
And come back to us in 10 years time. We'll see where he is.
Honestly like Claymore is a amazing Mongo. One of the best Mongols out there
[inaudible].
Finished. Like totally. Okay, good, good. Yeah.
22, 23 volumes. Um,
cause like the play more anime had a anime original ending if I remember. Yeah.
And it was complete from what I remember. Yeah.
I remember having a good time. I remember I watched a dub. The voice actor was,
uh, Greg was like playing the whiny characters he always does.
And I think he was a little too windy for like, I mean, that's just Greg Harris.
He's too good at his job.
No, no, because like, I, I remember that, that was like,
I swear he was typecast in that role for like the longest.
How many of those characters and no one else could do a voice like him.
It's like sounding whining. It was always him during the whiny character.
I'm going to say.
Seven out of 10. Honestly, I went no one.
That everyone was talking about the show like Jesus had came down himself and
brought a show and I watched it and I thought, honestly, this is kind of.
Like it's, it's good. But like it's kinda boring. Like,
is that how you feel about it? Obviously now I would give it a six.
Is that how you feel about Aurora proxy as well? You gave that a seven as well.
Oh, go proxy. I remember. I was just like, what the?
It's happening again? This doesn't seem like an anime that you would watch. No.
Like the ergo box is the last animal on it.
Watching. Like you don't when you go to a modern art museum and you look at the,
you're like, yeah, I get it.
That's what I felt. That's what I felt like
you've watched or proxy is like the same amount of like what the I would get if
you came up to me tomorrow and said, so I watched a serial experiments lane.
I've been wanting to watch that for a while. I just, I just haven't had the,
the opportunity to be like, yeah, I want to waste a day. Yeah. Not.
Not really enjoyable. Have a, an avid brain that.
I feel like you watch,
you watch shows like that to come out with like just your brain being like wet.
But like that's not fun half the time. So I don't remember.
I mean, it is fun depending on your mood, because I remember like, I,
I took me ages to watch serial experiments lane.
And then I was just in this weird mood where I'm just like, yeah, I,
I want my mind to be up. That, that sounds like exactly right now.
And then I did have a challenge. Yeah. It's like, it's like me with,
you asked me putting, put in like a wait,
I'm waiting to wake up for the day where I'm just like, yeah, I want,
I want depression right now.
Why the did I give, uh, this anime?
Yeah. I've noticed that. Why would you,
I was about to say you gave that a nine and I'm like,
wasn't the milk TVs. Is that what it is?
That's all I remember from that, that.
They get to the little two bonus points. But again,
that was in the same weekend that I watched the other show on the country will
48 hours.
Cause I remember mama, you HSA was like studio arms. And if you didn't know,
if you don't do the arms, they were like on their studio.
They were like famous for being a studio, like transitioned into animal.
That's probably why I've connected a little. And um, yeah, I mean,
that was like one of the first shows they produced.
That was an anime that was seen as just not complete trash,
but I wouldn't call it a nightmare.
Well sexual things going on or something like that. Some vibes of little set.
[inaudible].
I mean, I I'd say as an impressionable teenager,
I can see why you are connected with that on a personal level.
Yeah. I think that's pretty much everything. Cause uh,
you haven't rated a lot of them.
I would bump kill the kill up one for getting me in the hand tie.
That same thing I would.
To really killer killer killer is what made me be like, you know what?
I don't make girls a hot I'm like, you don't want.
I have this. And there was, and that's how I was like, Oh.
This is good. That's what you need to get into the gym shoes, man. Come on.
We know we're going to get him into that event. You can run away eventually.
Wait, wait. Okay. Then if you'd like to them, all you shot,
did you like long horizon?
I loved LA [inaudible] is one of my favorite shows. That makes sense.
It's written by the same people. I'm actually hype.
Even though I think I need to rewatch a little bit longer, long and season two.
I remember I loved the world. Yeah. Like in lockers. Yeah.
Boulder's, one of my money is a amazing, like, I don't know how.
They like write stories. I'm glad as well, stuff like that.
I'm also glad that the show didn't like blow its load,
like immediately and stop telling us everything about it. Like, yeah. I love it.
When the show is tease,
that's what the world like here's a little crumb crumbling knowledge.
And then you just don't mention it for a few episodes. You like, Oh. Yeah.
We already know we were in a video.
I forget because I remember log horizon.
I remember watching the first two or three episodes of it.
Dropped it immediately because I'm just like really? What,
what is this beat a sword art online, man, what the is this?
Because like the worst thing about locker horizon was that one,
like the animation is like, is like, great.
It's like the most typical five-hour 10 animation.
This is just a away seasonal show.
And the first three or so episodes will like the most generic kind of
introduction you can get to a world.
And it didn't start getting interesting until they probably started explaining
like the game mechanics and seeing, seeing the game mechanics being broken,
like within this world was just so interesting.
And that whole arc where like there was a guy who would kill him, the villages.
Yeah. Yeah.
What really you, you sold me immediately was like when they,
when they first discovered that they can make things taste good.
And then they like invented the burger. I was like, yo,
this is really interesting. This, this isn't even an ISA guy.
This is just like a, like an entrepreneur business.
[inaudible] was that's what? It was basically just like a business textbook.
Do you guys remember what happens in these like seven out of 10 shares bro?
The moment something isn't like exceptional. I'm like that's going in the.
Fellows look arrives is not a
[inaudible] whatever the.
It's called that went straight into it. Let's forget everything.
[Inaudible] was cool because again,
it was like against done by telling them my money.
Who's like somehow can like make you learn while reading these stories.
I don't know how he does it. I think I have a slight spice and Wolf. Right?
It's like spice and Wolf. Exactly. Like the reason why I love spice was because,
because like I actually learned like a proper like useful business skills for
read a minute. I'm just getting horny over this. If this Wolf wife,
I'm marketing genius, things about economics,
that's not law and that's not legal. That's not allowed. What are you,
what are you doing? I can't be horny and smart at the same time. How that works.
I feel like I have like amazing brain compression. Like I, my, my, my brain.
Zips, like, you.
Know how, like when you compress a file to like load the memory, it takes up.
That's what I do with animate immediately when I'm done. I'm like zip that up.
Put it in storage, forget about that thing. And then when we watched it,
it's like unzipping the farm, like, Oh yeah, this did happen. Has this man,
like min-max these brine? I don't actually think I've I've, you know,
I've sorted the storage on my brain appropriately.
You've got a sorting algorithm. Literally just veranda me my goal.